bonsoir rendre aux aidants ados merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france 60000 un spectateur à wembley
pour la demi finale on a vu ses
spectateurs entassés dans le stade dans
sa tranchée avec cette ambiance de crise
sanitaire qui perdure depuis plus d'un
an
c'est peut-être bien pour le sport mais
est-ce que ça n'a pas un côté un petit
peu insensé et déraisonnable forcément
qu il sera un comté a un côté insensé
puisqu'on sait que du côté des loups
gris où effectivement il y avait pas
déjà eu des cas de contamination par
rapport aux supporteurs qui se sont
déplacés suivre les différents matchs
qui se sont déroulés en hongrie
notamment ceux des équipes de l'équipe
de france c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a
la sensation depuis 48 heures que la
fonte des billets prend de la vitesse
que que le virus circule de plus en plus
vite et donc un plus grand nombre de
pays et que l'uefa ont fait n'est pas au
courant des skis se passe parce
qu'effectivement maintenir 60000
personnes dans la situation actuelle
dans un pays de toutes façons
l'angleterre qui est fortement touchée
cessez donc je re pour les semaines pour
le serena venir juste te rappeler est
par exemple qui a deux villes qui aurait
dû accueillir des matches des 17 euros
2020 et qui ne l'ont pas fait parce
qu'elles n'ont pas voulu suivre l'uefa
en ce qui concerne les jeux ce qui avait
été établi
c'est le cas des bilbao qui a renoncé à
recevoir des matches de la sélection
espagnole où c'est encore le cas des
dublin qui a aussi renoncé
donc on voit que depuis plusieurs
semaines il ya des pays avaient ville il
ya des responsables politiques qui
disent attention
peut-être qu'on est en train de
commettre une erreur et on voit
aujourd'hui effectivement quelle à
l'uefa regarde pour l'instant à ailleurs
et pas dans la bonne direction
clairement rendre aux aidants adria il
ya une part de responsabilité conjointe
de la part de
f1 qui a quand même mis la pression sur
les villes hôtes un pour accueillir un
maximum de supporters mais aussi de la
part d'eads et or autorités britanniques
qui devront donc accepter largement de
ne jouer joueurs on l'a vu sur les
images hier
effectivement les les autorités
britanniques qui jouent le jeu entre
guillemets qui permettait 60000
personnes parce que ça les intéresse et
économiquement parlant
et ça les intéresse et sportif en parle
en rappelant que les supporters
étrangers sont soumis à la quarantaine
et donc pour la plupart pour pouvoir pas
y aller voir les matchs du côté de
l'angleterre 7 cette fameuse finale
c'est vrai et que l'uefa a fait pression
sur différentes villes encore cet
exemple de bilbao qui n'a pas voulu
qu'il n'a pas voulu accueillir donc des
spectateurs dans son stade et donc elle
n'a pas eu des matches de l'euro mais
par contre dans le même pays
séville a bien voulu accueillir des
spectateurs est donc ramené à ramener du
monde sur sur les stades
pourquoi parce que derrière ça nous
n'oublions pas on a passé des moments
très difficiles
et puis ça derrière l'aspect sportif il
ya un aspect financier est qui et qui
est évident il ya un aspect aussi
politique beaucoup des gouvernements
doivent quand même se rattraper par des
mauvaises politiques ou de la mauvaise
communication
tout au long de la dernière année suite
à la pandémie et donc le fait de ramener
l'euro chez eux et d'avoir du monde dont
dans les stades ça ça leur permet en
quelque sorte de se justifier auprès des
leurs populations donc la responsabilité
et le n'est pas aux ligaments et vous
avez tout à fait raison à l'uefa elle
est aussi aux autorités des différents
pays qui ont décidé d'accueillir du
monde mais elle est aussi donc bien
évidemment évidemment aux eaux au club
qui ont essayé effectivement de faire en
sorte que des milliers des
téléspectateurs et des fans puisse
suivre leur leur équipe même si c'était
compliqué ça doit ses compétences
pardonnez moi ça paraît incroyable et
effectivement quand on voit ce stade
rempli d'anglais à l'aller pauvre
d'ailleurs danois on
en fait les frais c'est pas vraiment
l'esprit sportif as de permettre
uniquement aux supporters britanniques
d'être dans les stades et les autres et
bien tant pis ses yeux puisque ils n'ont
pas la chance d'habiter au royaume uni
c'est ça sent le même choquant et très
discriminant vu de l'extérieur c'est
c'est choquant c'est discriminant on
comprend pas effectivement les autorités
anglaises utile il ya il ya qu un côté
chauviniste chez les anglais
effectivement kiki qui interdisent la
c'est donc au stade aux supporters
bénodet de l'étranger ce qui est dommage
aussi c'est que les différents pays que
ce soit les danois les six très bien les
espagnols etc
les gouvernements de ces pays n'est pas
fait pression eux à son tour sur sur le
gouvernement britannique ont salué fa
pour qu'il puisse y avoir d'autres
d'autres supporters mais là on a
vraiment de problème est qu'ils se
rejoignent mais qui sont complètement
différents d'un côté c'est la première
question que vous avez posé vous avez
raison c est ce qu il est logique
d'avoir 60 mille personnes dans un stade
aujourd'hui et quand on voit la
circulation des virus delta notamment et
des ravages à qui peut faire est-ce que
d'un autre côté effectivement c est
sportivement parlant
normal que les supporters ne puisse pas
se porter lors leur équipe nationale
parce que il ya eu des décisions aux
politiques
ben il faut juste se rappeler et que les
anglais n'ont pas gagné et un titre
international depuis plus dix
cinquantaine d'années peut-être qu'avec
l'aide de l'uefa des arbitres et du
public anglais qui sera le solde dans le
stade
ils vont réussir cette fois ci merci en
tout cas rendre aux et de radio d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france ce
soir